random things i eat at yale
for breakfast we had mini bagels i
sprayed my cream cheese on with a spoon
and yeah it was kind of dry but it's
okay
moving on to lunch we have the best
salad bars they're literally always so
fresh this week's theme was citrus onion
i got some fat on the side just in case
for the entree there was a pita and
falafel sandwich with tahini the
falafels are always handmade by our
chefs and never dry at all
see they're so moist
and for dinner there's always a pasta
bar tonight we had pesto and tomato
sauce i always asked for extra cheese
inside as usual and to finish night off
there was brownie pudding and i had it
with some ice cream
what i eat in a day at yale brunch
edition
first things first kind of sanitize
and let's go take a look at what we got
today we had a bunch of options so i
grabbed the vegetarian one
[Music]
i also got some milk
some dessert
and finally a fruit smoothie so i had a
joke
that one right there is my sweet and i
finally made it back here's what
everything looks like
so we have eggs potatoes beyond patties
and asparagus the dessert today was a
sugar cookie and any brunch off with a
smoothie
coming dinner with me at yale tonight we
had korean chicken and fried rice of
course i got you behind the scenes it's
all made on the spot and it tastes so
good trust me i know my fried rice it
was still steaming and i got the tofu
and there's also kimchi in a little jar
so cute
we also had panna cotta and loki yeah
it's kind of like jiggly ice cream see
next i got a mini salad and yeah nothing
too special
and as usual i stopped by the pasta bar
and scott chuffed up some pesto pasta
this pasta never misses to finish dinner
off i have 11 bread good night bye
[Music]
why i eat a day at yale breakfast
edition as usual i get the oatmeal from
our opening station we always have a
bunch of topping options thanks joe for
knowing the topping i don't really like
the dried fruit
breakfast was actually fried today we
also had breakfast sandwiches i got the
vegetarian with beyond meat egg and
pesto then we randomly had a spinach
quiche and of course i had to try it was
good but just kind of cold you know
and here's where i got some juice but
next we had this almond twirly thingy
and you already know i finished day off
with the yogurt
[Music]
you